NEXT 12.5 SECONDS.
TRAE YOUNG HAS GOT IT.
IN THE PAINT, HE TIED THE GAME.
NO TIMEOUTS EITHER WAY.
SEVEN SECONDS.
KLAY COME ALONG.
-- KLAY, LONG.
LOONEY, YES!
THE WARRIORS WIN!
LOONEY ON A 20 REBOUND NIGHT.
HIS SECOND FOLLOW GIVES THE
WARRIORS THE WIN.
KELENNA: GIVE THAT MAN THE GAME
BALL.
THAT IS PURE EFFORT, WHO WANTS
IT MORE.
BOB: LOONEY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
14 POINTS, 21 BOARDS, FIVE
ASSISTS.
THEY WENT TO REPLAY TO CONFIRM
IT.
IT WAS GOOD.
WHAT A WIN.
THE WARRIORS WIN FIVE AND A ROW
ON THE HOMESTAND.
THEY ARE 17.2 IN THE BUILDING.
LOONEY SENDS HOME.
KELENNA: HE SAYS WE ARE NOT
GOING TO A THIRD OVERTIME.
THIS IS OVER.
KLAY GOT THE LAST SHOT, SMALL
DEFENDER TRYING TO BOX OUT.
YOU HAD A COUPLE OF
OPPORTUNITIES.
BOB: KLAY THOMPSON ON A 54 POINT
NIGHT.
THE WARRIORS LOVE IT.
KEVON LOONEY, WHO MIGHT BE THE
MOST POPULAR WARRIOR AMONGST HIS
TEAMMATES, WHO DOES ALL THE HARD
WORK, HE GETS THE BUZZER BEATER.
KELENNA: THAT IS A DEVASTATING
LOSS.
BOB: KLAY THOMPSON HAD 54.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING LEFT FOR
THE INTERVIEW?
KLAY: MY TANK IS ON E.
THANK GOD FOR KEVON LOONEY.
STRIKES AGAIN.
BOB: I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK TO
A CONVERSATION ON THE TEAM BUS
LEAVING BROOKLYN.
AS DOWN AS A TEAM WAS ON THAT
ROAD TRIP, YOU SAID WE ARE
COMING HOME AND THERE ARE BETTER
DAYS AHEAD.
YOU SPOKE IT INTO EXISTENCE.
WHAT FLIPPED THE SWITCH?
KLAY: I THINK IT WAS YOUR
INSPIRATIONAL TALK.
I APPRECIATE YOU FORESEEING THIS
HAPPEN.
YOU HAVE SOME SKILLS.
THAT WAS A GREAT CONVERSATION WE
HAD ON THE ROAD TRIP, SO IT IS
FUN TO GET THOSE WINS BACK IN
FRONT OF OUR FANS.
BOB: TALK ABOUT THE WORK YOU
HAVE DONE DEFENSIVELY DOWN THE
STRETCH ON THIS HOMESTAND?
KEVON LOONEY HOLDING DOWN THE
PAINT.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO COME AWAY
WITH THESE IMPROBABLE WINS?
KLAY: A GUTSY EFFORT FROM
EVERYBODY.
THE FINGER ROLL.
JUST AN ALL-AROUND STRENGTH IN
NUMBERS EFFORT.
SO PROUD OF EVERYBODY.
BOB: YOUR FIRST 50 BALL SINCE
COMING BACK FROM THE SURGERIES.
54.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE NEVER GOING
TO BECOME A GREAT PLAYER AGAIN
-- THAT IS WHAT KNUCKLEHEADS ARE
SAYING.
THEY CAN TAKE THAT 54 AND STICK